you know the old saying
no news is good news well where kovit's
concerned
why does it always seem like good news
is actually bad news
well just as the ingram angle told you
months ago biden
has not one but two running mates
well there's kamala right we know about
kamala
and then there's covet the more active
across the country
they both are the less old joe has to
campaign for himself
now the problem for the biden coveted
ticket is that the virus is slowing down
just like the presidential nominee
himself
come on man well in the last two weeks
the average number of daily covet cases
has plummeted
17 now remember when we were first sold
the lockdowns
it was all about saving the hospitals it
was very important to do that
well check out the latest data on covet
hospitalizations by age group
from the cdc it's down down
down among all age groups the
hospitalizations and deaths in arizona
in texas and in florida also continue to
decline
sharply this is all good news
we continue to make progress in our
fight against the china virus
new weekly cases have declined by 44
percent
since july deaths declined by 20
compared to just last week it's going
down very rapidly
well of course dr fauci could not let an
upbeat view go without critique
i have to disagree with that because if
you look at the thing that you just
mentioned the statistics
andrea they're they're disturbing you
know we're we're plateauing
at around 40 000 cases a day
and the deaths are around a thousand
okay
again we don't know how many of those
one thousand people
died from covid or with covid
and dr fauci didn't elaborate on that
but he did drop this bombshell
if you're talking about getting back to
a degree of normality which resembles
where we were
prior to covid it's going to be well
into 2021
maybe even towards the end of 2021
okay let me translate that for you if
biden wins you're going to be locked
down
on and off for most of the next year
plus
now when biden says he's going to listen
to the doctors it's not just dr
fauci he also means epidemiologist
michael
osterholm from the university of
minnesota who co-authored a piece
several weeks ago
urging that we quote commit to a more
restrictive lockdown state by state
for up to six weeks to crush the spread
of the virus
okay the assumption being that doing so
would stop the virus well dr osterholm
is widely expected to be a likely
candidate for a top job
in the biden administration he genuinely
seems to despise red state america where
people have just decided you know we
understand the risk
but we have to move on with our lives
think about this
in kentucky and in lots of other states
they're now playing
high school football in other sports in
texas
they're going to in person school five
days a week
in tennessee people are scheduling
weddings again
in nebraska they're now in stage four
meaning
it's back to normal kids are in school
and learning
and that means what does it mean the
media has to push the panic
24 7 all the more especially about the
schools
now look at these scary headlines
terrible
okay about the teachers now every loss
of life is horrible
but as many including the washington
examiner pointed out what these stories
have in common
there is no evidence that any of the
teachers
mentioned contracted the virus while
teaching
and if any one thing drives the left off
the ledge
it's an indoor trump rally where people
are having
fun like last night's in nevada
the event was in defiance of state
regulations his leadership is killing
people
this is the white house telling us that
they really have a callous disregard for
human life
he chose to show callous disregard
in a reckless selfish irresponsible way
it was an anti-science rally
in nevada
as usual they're all super spreaders of
hypocrisy
always complaining about what regular
americans
are doing to try to go on and live
normal lives you know that whole pursuit
of happiness thing
but they never complain none of them
when hordes of looters
race into stores smash through cities
and basically do whatever they want
whenever they want to
and when they're in a desperate need of
a blowout
well of course mask optional of course
well although governors from florida to
south dakota recognize that covid
is a horrible tragedy and that many
might still die from it
they've taken shutdowns off the table
well they've done that
because the societal cost to daily life
to everything about the lives we lead is
just too high
first lockdowns don't work just look at
the number of cases rising in europe if
you think
if you think they do work second the
damage they cause is catastrophic to our
economy
our children's education we're all
saying that mental health
and our safety by the way they're also
illegal
today a federal district judge in
pennsylvania issued a
stinging 66-page rebuke
striking down governor tom wolf's
emergency coveted measures citing
multiple
constitutional violations violated the
first amendment right of assembly
the due process clause and the equal
protection clause
of the 14th amendment judge william
strickman wrote the response to a
pandemic or emergency
cannot be permitted to undermine the
system of checks and balances
here defendants are statutorily
permitted to act with little if any
meaningful
input from the legislature the
constitution cannot accept the concept
of a new normal
where the basic liberties of a people
can be subordinated to
open-ended emergency mitigation measures
now it was a phenomenal ruling and we've
been telling you this for months
our constitutional rights may not be
indefinitely a bridge by executive fiat
period
now i expect similar challenges to be
launched in other blue states by
businesses
parents schools and churches who at this
point are just fed up with being shut
down
but remember for biden's team
it will never be the right time to
return power to the people
so i think of it this way if you want to
see your grandparents next year
if you want your son to have an actual
graduation ceremony
now if you're a college student and you
want to be on campus
if you want to watch march madness for
goodness sakes or you want to go to
easter sunday services
you should not vote for biden because if
he wins
none of that is going to happen not even
in red states
the doctors will always tell him it's
not safe until we
have an effective vaccine that has been
successfully administered
to most americans whether we want it or
not
the consequences will be disastrous
millions of jobs will be permanently
lost and all of america
will start looking like new york in
california rolling blackouts
rolling rioters and blm radicals have
the run of the streets
unchecked and unchallenged the choice
in november day by day could not be
clearer
liberty or lockdown strength
or submission the constitution
or chaos and that's the angle